this video is sponsored by surf shark
VPN if you're in need of a VPN and won a
great deal on it stay tuned till the end
of the video if you're watching this
video you're probably familiar with the
story of the disastrous and also comical
Battle of Kadesh as it is by far my most
popular video to date however I ended
the video on a note of we don't know
what exactly happened because quite
frankly I did not have the time to go on
a rabbit hole hunt for some maybe
nonexistent primary sources about the
battle but now we're back here well over
a year from my original video and I have
managed to find some extra sources about
the battle that may shine some light on
the actual events that happened near can
establish that September of 1788 so the
story I presented at the start of my
first video is the main story that is
presented on most websites including
Wikipedia to a certain extent that story
is true but widely over-exaggerated for
example to ridiculously high 10000
casualty count comes from an 1834 French
publication which most certainly took
some liberties to portray the rival
Austrian army as incompetent continue
off from there we can presume there were
many more secondhand publications mostly
from rivaled Austrian countries taking
large liberties with the facts or even
making up new ones such as the made-up
order of an artillery fire directed
straight into an Austrian camp or the
fact that the Austrian military was
carrying a chest with the entire Army's
payroll which we know was in an Austrian
military practice suddenly when looking
at all of these made-up facts about the
battle it may start to seem like the
events of canosa beshe were just made up
by austrian rivals as to diminish their
prestige in european politics however
that is very unlikely as there are too
many articles from different countries
talking about the same event this also
combined with the fact that it wasn't
just foreign articles that talked about
the Battle of Kadesh and there were
Austrian publications as well means that
it is highly implausible that the story
was made up in fact the Sabre story
presented in my first video is a
centuries-long amalgamation of second
hand over exaggerated narratives of an
event
most likely wasn't as drastic as it is
made out to be today so to get away from
this bias and number exaggerations
records from the actual September of
1788 have to be consulted these are as
numerous as the second-hand
nineteenth-century records but there is
enough of them to make out what happened
in Canada bish there are multiple non
German Austrian sources from 1788 that
talked about the Battle of Kadesh but
they all seem to be reciting the German
and Austrian publications overall it
seems like there are three main writings
that claim to have first-hand sources or
interviewed first ten sources like the
soldiers from the battle one of these
writings are the official ultimate
military accounts which naturally can
give us a full picture as they were on
the other side of the war but can
provide valuable information information
like the fact that the Ottoman troops
were ready to engage the Austrian army
only for them to find out in late
September that the Austrians withdrew
from the strategically important image
setting a gap of which cannot submerge
lies on the north and end of I mentioned
this source in my first video but what I
didn't mention it was a different
Ottoman source that accredits the
Austrian withdrawal to the Austrian fear
of facing the terrifying ottoman army
however this is obviously just Ottoman
propaganda at play but the first source
is still sound giving us a solid ground
to stand on knowing that the Austrians
did in fact retreat from cabbage for
some reason so now we have to look at
the German and Austrian sources claiming
to have first-hand records the first of
these sources the politicians are now
from Hamburg seems like a good place to
start as it gives personal testimonies
from witnesses and sites official
Austrian court documents it tells us
that a skirmish did happen between the
Ottomans and Austrians at some point in
early September of 1788 the skirmish
most likely occurred somewhere near the
timur zelma gap as it says that the
kaiser ordered a retreat vehicle and
submerge towered stem eshwara during
this confusing retreat the local
villages which saw an opportunity to rob
the Austrian soldiers started to spread
rumors throughout the army that the
ottomans were in close pursuit getting
ready to attack at any moment this
turned a withdrawal
into a disorderly panicked mess
during which two Austrian regiments
managed to run into each other due to
the confusion and an expected Ottoman
ambush both regiments mr. key cheddar
for Ottoman soldiers and open fire they
quickly noticed their mistake but the
damage was already done that is where
the German source ends the story and
continues on talking about the bigger
picture ramifications of the retreat
the source doesn't mention if there were
any casualties or deaths but it is most
likely that there were at least a couple
going out from there checking the
Austrian article from real Satan there
are some similarities with the German
source but also some differences one of
the similarities being that the initial
confusion was started by valakians
however the way they started it does
differ from the German source according
to the Austrian source the panicked
confusion didn't happen during the
armies retreat but while it was encamped
near the town of Calais Abeche
apparently with the intention of robbing
the camp
Valachi and started to yell turks turks
causing a confusion and fear throughout
the camp the austrian article continues
on saying that during the confusion two
regiments mistook each other for Ottoman
soldiers and opened fire just as in the
German source but the Austrian article
does give marks for nation of why the
soldiers mr each other for ottomans
saying that the soldiers opened fire
only after miss hearing a health command
from one of the opposing regiment
officers as an ottoman battle cry allah
however after a few shots fired the
soldiers quickly realized their mistake
and stopped that is where the account
ends and the article continues on
talking about the military actions of
the austrian army as they decided to
retreat from cairo seviche so even
though the austrian source does differ a
little bit from the german source the
two tell a pretty similar overarching
story showing us that the main
underlying element of the battle was
fear of ottoman attack sparked by local
colossians after which during the
confusion two regiments accidentally
opened fire on each other thinking the
other one was the enemy so even though
today the Battle of karin-sama SH is
remembered as a drunken scuffle turned
bad that in the end was responsible for
10,000 casualties the true story is far
milder however the truth
never
stops people from embellishing the facts
especially when they haven't had an
agenda to push or an entertaining story
to tell
speaking of entertaining stories to tell
surf shark VPN can be very useful
whether you're trying to secure your
sensitive data when browsing the web or
access to your restricted content like
the suite Netflix and HBO shows it can
help you avoid price discrimination or
get past Internet censorship and to help
you with all this surf shark VPN is
giving you 83 percent discount which
unlocks the best price on the market as
well as one extra month for free all you
got to do is either hit the link in the
description or type in surf shark the
deal /m laser and enter the promo code
and laser thank you for surf shark for
sponsoring this video hope you enjoyed
this explanation video it was long time
in the making and I admit there are
still certain elements I either didn't
talk about for time sake or remain
unexplained or undefined due to the
lackluster sources I've managed to find
but I just felt like it was time to end
this project as I have already spent a
lot of time on it please consider
subscribing and hitting the bell button
if you want to be notified every time I
release a video which is once a month
and until then stick around for history